[Applauso]
siamo tutti diversi io sono diverso da
voi voi siete diversi da me voi siete
diversi da voi tutta questa diversità
sollevato un grande problema un problema
comunicativo un problema ha causato a
tutte quelle differenze che possono
essere religiose culturali geografiche
via dicendo questo grande problema ha
portato alla popolazione mondiale ad un
grande quesito
qual è il miglior metodo di
comunicazione come facciamo a
comprenderci capirci se siamo così
diversi
sinceramente penso che la popolazione
mondiale si stia parlando in un gran
bicchiere d'acqua perché la soluzione si
trova proprio sotto il nostro naso sotto
il naso di tutti qual è questa soluzione
è semplice mi basta soltanto una parola
una parola che da sola vale milioni
anziché dico miliardi parole messe
insieme
emozioni cosa ci rende allo stesso tempo
sia diversi che uguali le emozioni cosa
è rimasto invariato nel passare degli
anni le emozioni cosa ci fa sentire vivi
a guarda un po le emozioni emozioni e
sentimenti che bello vero sono speciali
e tutti noi le possediamo anche se a
volte non ci rendiamo conto le
nascondiamo di proposito
a dir la verità nasconderle non ha
proprio senso perché sono facili da
riconoscere
basta osservare osservare le braccia le
mani le gambe gli occhi il volto è
semplice c'è bisogno soltanto di un po
di concentrazione e il gioco è fatto
tutti possono comprare alle emozioni di
chiunque da chi vi è vicino quando
salite per esempio sul treno o dalle
strano che adesso avete a fianco con voi
sto portando avanti il concetto di
comprensione delle mozioni un concetto
facilmente definibile in una singola
parola
l'empatia personalmente io e non solo
utilizzo l'empatia per un qualcosa che
amo la clown therapy che cos'è la clown
therapy ve lo spiego in parole semplici
ovvero rendo o almeno ci provo a rendere
felici a ridurre lo stress a distaccare
i pazienti da quell ansia e malinconia
che prende il sopravvento travestito da
clown sono diventato clown da poco e
faccio parte di un'associazione barese
grazie a loro la mia vita è cambiata
grazie a loro la mia vita ha preso una
svolta in questo fantastico mondo ho
compreso quanto siano importanti le
emozioni e di quanto sia fondamentale
comprende ma soprattutto faletra sparire
inoltre ha preso un nuovo concetto di
famiglia una famiglia che aiuta e si
aiuta l'uno con l'altro per il bene di
tutti e di se stessi
conservo gelosamente questa foto perché
oltre a essere bellissima rapporto
turion mente questo concetto di famiglia
che sto portando avanti una famiglia di
tanti supereroi tutti diversi ma con lo
stesso identico obiettivo dare una mano
e regalare sorriso
qualche giorno fa il 2 febbraio 2019
una delle date più importanti della mia
vita perché perché è stato il primo
turno in corsia per la precisione in
chirurgia pediatrica e nel reparto di
pronto soccorso è stata una giornata
particolare perché ho vissuto tante
emozioni tante emozioni che a pensarci
ancora oggi mi fa furono tutte nello
stomaco
tante emozioni tutte diverse che
mischiandosi tra loro hanno creato una
sorta di pastrocchio così grande e
complesso da essere è indescrivibile a
parole vorrei raccontarvi uno di questi
momenti perché questa è la giornata è
stata una giornata piena di momenti
momenti difficili che perché non sapevo
cosa fare come comportarmi e momenti
bellissimi momenti che mi hanno fatto
fermare un attimo e dire wow momenti che
mi hanno sciolto momenti che mi sono
rimasti impressi e che mirano impressi
per molto tempo se non per sempre
vorrei raccontarvi appunto uno di questi
momenti che ha come protagonista una
bambina bellissima di nome mi sa che
stava nel reparto di pronto soccorso ma
che aveva uno sguardo così tanto truce
da non incute paura ma un senso di
tristezza
però grazie all'aiuto dei miei colleghi
e soprattutto grazie alle bolle di
sapone
sono riuscita a farla ridere e a
scorgere quel sorriso che ha mai
stanziato ma è soprattutto il fatto che
dopo prima di andarsene salutato me e
ripeto me mi ha messo definitivamente ko
perché non me l'aspettavo e soprattutto
è una cosa fantastica
in questo fantastico mondo quello della
clown terapia per andare bene un turno
per avere un successo non c'è bisogno di
un trucco stupendo o di gadget così
tanto incredibili da lasciare a bocca
aperta sia i colleghi che pazienti c'è
bisogno di tutt'altro
se vi sono soltanto di un bel naso rosso
ed i tre punti fondamentali
concentrazione fiducia e improvvisazione
concentrazione perché bisogna sempre
essere attenti comprende la situazione e
agire di conseguenza fiducia perché per
andare un bene un turno il paziente deve
fiducia in te e tu avere fiducia in lui
e infine l'improvvisazione perché non
sai mai a cosa può andare incontro e
quindi bisogna sempre essere pronti
vorrei soffermarmi particolarmente su
quest'ultimo punto vero quello
dell'improvvisazione perché l'arte in
progettazione è un arte magica che ho
sempre adorato soprattutto per la
produzioni così è una delle mie più
grandi passioni perché le poesie come le
emozioni sono facile riconoscere quindi
anche loro universali così emozioni
coesistono tra loro e inoltre a poesia
ovunque e può essere qualsiasi cosa è
oggi ve lo dimostrerò avendo fortuna 31
pubblico con cui interagire
chiederò a uno di voi la prima parola
che verrà in mente componendo al momento
una breve poesia in rima qualche
volontario situ
sì sto parlando con te qualcuno che
porta il microfono
dimmi la prima parola che ti viene in
mente grazie seris sorriso e una parola
interessante complimenti allora sorriso
ok il sorriso è una cosa fantastica se
se se non unica perché perché rende ogni
atmosfera magica ma solo se il sorriso
viene condiviso potremmo dire di stare
veramente in paradiso perché perché
rende chiunque lo guarda felice dopo una
giornata beffarda quindi per favore
sorridete
perché soltanto così ve lontano andrete
avete visto sono riuscito a fare una
poesia anche con la parola sorriso ma
quando è nata questa mia grande passione
è nata a tanto tempo fa quando era
ancora piccola andavo in terza
elementare quando la mia insegnata anzi
la mia maestra a segno per caso ma poi
sia facilissima da imparare a memoria ma
alla fine c'era un problema ovvero che
non riusciva impararla
ma grazie al continuo ripete ripetere
ripetere la ricordo ancora oggi è
infatti recita così dove vanno le foglie
ingiallite che il vento stacca dagli
alberi volano e passano mormorio
dell'area e tutto quello che rimane
dall'autunno
nonostante i mii ritenersi molto
soddisfatto anzi ultra soddisfatto di
quello che ho fatto appunto c'era un
problema ovvero che questa poesia non mi
piaceva per niente non era i miei gusti
anche se quei tempi non aveva un
concetto di gusto ma all'improvviso una
lampadina si accese all'improvviso
arriva l'idea lì proprio in quel punto
nacque iniziativa li decisi di scrivere
una poesia in rima dello stesso
argomento che però non porta in classe
preferite nella per me
però a cosa è servita a questa azione
grazie a questa azione grazie a questa
poesia
ho iniziato a coltivare un qualcosa che
è ormai mi caratterizza
ma con questo cosa voglio dirvi voglio
dirvi che noi tutti dovremmo e ripeto
dovremo sfruttare le nostre emozioni
perché possono esserci sempre utili per
le nostre passioni come la poesia o per
farci nome amici nuove esperienze nuove
occasioni o perché no per ideare il
nostro nuovo sistema di comunicazione e
dunque dunque importante focalizzarci su
i tre punti fondamentali quello della
concentrazione perché è importantissimo
valutare e comprendere le vastità delle
diversità che ci circondano e inoltre
anche la fiducia importante perché
soltanto allargando le braccia verso ciò
che è diverso potremo ottenere quella
ricchezza di cui non abbiamo ancora
usufruito e infine l'improvvisazione
perché abbiamo sempre bisogno di quella
naturalezza e fantasia in più per
comprendere aiutare chiunque da chi ci
sembra più in difficoltà a chi ci sembra
più privilegiato e dunque quando vuoi
tornare a casa quando tutto questo sarà
finito
vi chiedo di rendere vostre emozioni e
le vostre relazioni con gli altri delle
meravigliose poesie non vi preoccupate
se non saranno del tutto totalmente il
vostro gradimento
perché l'importante che nella poesia
bella o brutta che sia è che ci sia non
solo impegno ma soprattutto
collaborazione perché soltanto così
soltanto così potremo raggiungere
traguardi inimmaginabili
soltanto così potremo ideare e trovare
quei codici per programmare un nuovo
mondo un mondo dove è facile
comprendersi anche con un sorriso perché
no anche con un naso rosso perché il
naso rosso si lo so può imbarazzare ma
vi assicuro credetemi che il naso rosso
crea davvero emozioni e soprattutto
unisce quindi il mio augurio per il
futuro è soltanto uno quello di avere
almeno una volta nella
it e coraggio di portare naso rosso
grazie
[Applauso]